[Musique]
après une année de stage les cadets de
la gendarmerie ont terminé leur
formation par une cérémonie au camp
militaire de ben vendredi 29 avril
soixante jeunes de 17 à 21 ans ont fait
passer aux autorités et à leurs familles
nous vous emmenons dans les coulisses de
la préparation à l'occasion de la
journée mondiale des mobilités et de
l'accessibilité le samedi 30 avril
dernier un nouvel autocar sont % équipés
pour les personnes à mobilité réduite a
été inauguré à guyancourt son nom accès
6 il peut accueillir jusqu'à dix
fauteuils roulants et puis le à dos est
un sport d'un nouveau genre entre le jeu
vidéo et la balle au prisonnier deux
équipes combattent à l'aide de boules
d'énergie et de boucliers un premier
tournoi initiatique est organisée dont
les yvelines direction la verrière pour
découvrir la discipline
[Musique]
je crois que il faut qu'on remette à
plat un certain nombre d'idées
la façon d exprimer j'ai eu l'occasion
de dire à d'autres médias dans cette
campagne pardonnez moi j'espère que les
enfants ne nous regarde pas je vais
utiliser un gros mot je nous ai trouvés
chiant
pas d'idées nouvelles pas d'aspérités en
train de feu sa marque est de vie tout
ça et je crois que pour mener une
campagne présidentielle il faut à la
fois parler bien sûr le langage de la
raison il parlait programme il faut
aussi parler le langage du coeur il faut
se lâcher il faut il faut faire rêver
les français
[Musique]
je pense qu'il faut qu'on soit une
droite explicative et une droite assumé
nous commettons une erreur de diagnostic
j'entends partout les idées de droite
sont majoritaires totalement fou les
idées droite ne sont pas que tour de
l'autorité du besoin de l'autorité
l'idée centrale de la bande c'est la
liberté il faut expliquer aux français
que c'est à nous que monsieur macron
prétend nous donner de la liberté mais
qui ne nous en donne pas et que nous
notre objectif c'est la liberté
d'entreprendre la liberté d'assumer sa
vie individuelle la liberté individuelle
c'est cette liberté là qui nous
protègera or n'est plus protégé par la
liberté que par l'égalité car je
comprends bien dans ce monde troublé que
les français ce besoin de protection
bien il vaut mieux plus de liberté que
plus d'égalité pour répondre à ce besoin
de protection et sa cette philosophie là
je pense qu'elle nous a monté
je trouve que dans les grandes
difficultés que connaît la france ça ce
n'est pas absurde de travailler avec le
président réélu la ligne qui a été
choisie est donc celle d'une opposition
mais ce sera en tout cas pour ce qu'on
veut dans les yvelines une opposition
constructive
[Musique]
accès 6 c'est le nom de cet autocar un
peu particulier il peut accueillir
jusqu'à dix fauteuils roulants le groupe
lacroix et sa vague possède trois
véhicules de ce type les mairies nous
sollicitent régulièrement pour des
transport des personnes à mobilité
réduite et donc nous avons imaginé ce
véhicule qui peut transporter 10
fauteuils en même temps et il est
modulable donc de 42 places assises
jusqu'à dix places assises et en
fonction fait varier le nombre de
fauteuils de un à dix fauteuils qui est
bien sûr semblait dans le véhicule autre
option dans ce bus des toilettes aux
normes pmr cet équipement vos quatre
cent mille euros et pourrait s'intégrer
dans une offre de transports publics
destinés aux personnes à mobilité
réduite aujourd'hui ce qui est important
pour nous c'est de savoir que ce type de
véhicule existe pas en mode prototype
c'est l'industriel c'est la petite série
mais c'est important de voir que cette
offre serre et qu'elle a aujourd'hui une
réalité une utilité sur nos territoires
en particulier vis-à-vis des ccas les
centres communaux d'action sociale qui
ont des besoins de mobilité spécifiques
et aujourd'hui il ya un vrai plus de
voir ce type de véhicule arriver sur nos
territoires les associations comme l'afm
téléthon pourrait également être
intéressé par ce type de véhicule nous
pourrions être intéressée pour déplacer
toutes nos tous nos malades vers le
généthon que nous allons visiter
régulièrement par exemple à evry toutes
les structures pour l'école enfin où les
enfants malades vont par exemple se
rendre ça pourrait être une solution
aussi actuellement nous avons nous avons
beaucoup de soucis pour les taxis qui
transportent les enfants en fauteuil
encore de nombreuses problématiques à
résoudre pour l'accessibilité le groupe
lacroix et savak possède le plus grand
nombre de véhicules pmr en ile de france
[Musique]
chants pas cadencés ordre serré nous
voici plongés dans les coulisses de la
préparation de la cérémonie militaire
des cadets de la gendarmerie le
lendemain c'est 60 jeunes clôtureront
leur année de stage
pour leur apprendre d'arriver en paca
danser sur les sur la place d'armes de
se mettre en position est de répondre à
tous les ordres que je vais leur donner
en tant que commandant des troupes donc
il est important de passer du temps et
du temps à répéter pour que ce soit
parfait le jour j
chacun alors il y en a ils vont passer
devant tout le monde après il ya le
président qui va parler devant toulon
mais sinon chaque peloton et une
cérémonie importante puisqu'elle se
déroulera devant les autorités mais
surtout devant leur famille au clown à
la sonnerie
tambours c'est stressant parce que il
faut obéir aux ordres il faut être
vigilant pendant très longtemps parce
qu'il ya des temps d'attentes
on se met toujours en place un peu avant
donc il faut attendre on est debout
parfois il fait chaud donc c'est
toujours stressant et face aux familles
on a toujours un petit peu ce trac qui
est toujours un petit problème pour moi
c'est assez stressant parce que c'est
nouveau mais on est c'est très bien
expliqué pour nous donc je pense que ça
va aller on en parle aussi dans nos
foyers dans nos familles pour vous
raconte tout ce qui se passe au sein de
au sein des trois stages donc là le fait
de pouvoir leur montrer de leur montrer
tout ce qu'on apprend les marches qu'on
apprend les champs aussi qu'on apprend
on est on est fier je demande tout ça et
on est content on écoute on pour leur
montrer au sein d'une cérémonie comme 7
6 l'occasion aussi de jeter un coup
d'oeil amusé au premier jour de stage
lorsque les cadets n'en étaient qu'à
leurs premiers balbutiements c'est le
jour et la nuit où ils sont arrivés
vierge de toute connaissance et de
compétence militaire et maintenant donc
ils sont des vrais petits soldats prêts
à marcher au pas et obéir aux ordres
faut avoir une très grande cohésion avec
le peloton
s'il ya quelqu'un qui fait un faux pas
tous ceux qui sont derrière font un faux
pas donc c'est assez compliqué donc
c'est pour ça on le travaille énormément
mais maintenant ça va
[Musique]
et le fameux jour est enfin arrivé
lecture dépôt de gerbe minute de silence
ou encore des filets tout se passe comme
prévu pour ces jeunes cadets une
cérémonie orchestrée dans les moindres
détails qui fait office de symbole elle
fait partie des traditions des
traditions qui sont au coeur même de
l'identité militaire de la gendarmerie
et donc c'est la plus belle
reconnaissance au programme remise
d'insignes et de brevets
une fierté pour les cadets et leurs
familles tu très ému d'avoir ce diplôme
parce que ça montre que j'ai un
engagement dans la gendarmerie pour
parce que plus tard je vais te la
gendarmerie donc je suis très fier de ma
famille est elle est là va même à
regarder tout le long de la cérémonie
elle était très fière beaucoup de photos
je suis content parce qu'on a pu on a pu
marcher devant devant nos familles on a
pu on a pu marcher face à des autorités
face au général et c'était un grand
moment et c'était c'est émouvant ici
pour nous comme pour les autorités
présentes dans un moment où les faits
qui m'ont dit les jeunes sont en perte
de repères et sont toujours à la
recherche de sens dans leur vie on a là
le parfait exemple de jeunes qui eux
s'engagent et souhaite donner du sens
alors à leur vie de tous les jours et
viennent ici mesurer grâce à ce
dispositif si ce métier est fait pour
eux aujourd'hui s'engager pour son pays
s'engager pour la sécurité de ses
concitoyens c'est noble c'est une source
de fierté et notre présence aujourd'hui
c'est une manière de dire merci à tous
ces jeunes qui sont engagés dans ce
dispositif et qui vont demain et bien
continuer à travailler au service de
notre pays notre république de voir
leurs regards pendant la cérémonie qui
pétillent où on voit certains qui le 26
septembre dernier qui est un peu comme
on dit un peu inquiet ou un peu
dubitatif plus se poser question et de
le voir aujourd'hui fière et être en
fait des femmes et des hommes ne sera
pas pris une fin de stage qui signe un
nouveau départ pour beaucoup d'entre eux
concours de sous-officier de la
gendarmerie de la police nationale ou
encore de l'administration pénitentiaire
ils sont nombreux à vouloir s'engager
depuis tout petit je vais dans la
gendarmerie et ce stage cadets m'a
confirmé mon choix professionnels je
vais je vais passer mes études et je
vais je vais prétendre au concours de
sous-officier pour entrer au sein la
gendarmerie le recrutement de la
prochaine promo de cadets de la
gendarmerie commencera en septembre
prochain objectif 120 cadets en 2022
[Musique]
ce lundi 2 mai on se retrouve au gymnase
de la fraternité à l'intérieur pour le
tournoi à dos des sites est fantastique
c'est le premier dans les yvelines et le
ados en fait c'est un sport d'un nouveau
genre qui se pratique en réalité
augmentée une balle au prisonnier
futuriste entre dragon ball z et street
fighter à l'origine du tournoi la siac
donc l'association pour la création et
l'innovation artistique et culturelle
dont vous êtes le directeur nadir yole
un bon soir avec nous
et puis également un partenariat avec la
villa de la verrière puisque nous sommes
avec vous qui rit quintavalle vous vous
êtes responsable du sport et de la vie
associative
merci d'être avec nous alors je me
tourne vers vous une interview l'un pour
la première question c'est le premier
sport d'équipé en rien en réalité
augmentée comment ça se déroule
concrètement absolument c'est le premier
sport c'est du 3 contre 3 comme une
balle au prisonnier on a des capteurs de
mouvements un casque de réalité
augmentée donc qui augmentent est une
sorte de vision de holographique une
arène tout autour on a un ensemble
logiciel en bacs et ben écoute le chacun
un viseur en fait sur lui comme grande
rose et on peut construire des boucliers
holographique comme un peu dans black
panther et on a des boules d'énergie
style kamehameha et on doit viser un peu
comme si on jetait une boule de tennis
on doit viser en stratégie avec son
équipe l'équipe adverse et éviter les
boules d'énergie qui viennent nous
touchent et ados ça veut dire vibration
donc ce qu'on voit des fois dans les
jeux vidéo hadoken voilà est donc en
fait l'idée c'est de baffes d'avoir
suffisamment de boucliers on est limité
d'un gérer son énergie et avoir le plus
de mouvements possibles sur des matchs
cours comme le squash une minute trente
et un ont fait
or match tout et tout et très physique
et en même temps on est en mise en abyme
comme dans un jeu vidéo et justement il
ya des accessoires essentiels pour jouer
absolument capteur de mouvements casque
de réalité augmentée tout l'ensemble du
software et et la reine qui relie le
capteur de mouvement et les hologrammes
dans le jeu en faisant découvrir cette
discipline aux vielles au verrier ouais
c'est quoi l'objectif ici bas ça peut
diversifier les activités c'est vraiment
une nouvelle activité qui est dans l'air
du temps autour de la réalité augmentée
des jeux vidéo c'est notre manière
d'appréhender aussi ce monde là donc
c'est hyper les enfants fait le découvre
et son sont émerveillés quoi parce
qu'ils sont immergés dans un jeu là donc
voilà c'est au lieu de rester dans la
télé ben là ils peuvent ils peuvent le
vivre c'est à la fois physique et
sportif et c'est tout de suite
accessible on peut s'amuser tout de
suite en fait c'est en fait on vit est
réellement les jeux vidéo auxquels on
joue et on pouvait jouer avant parce que
c'est pour tous les âges à on y
reviendra dans un instant aujourd'hui on
se trouve donc au gymnase on l'a dit à
la verrière pour accueillir le tournoi
est ce que c'est parce qu'il faut des
conditions particulières ont finalement
on peut y jouer partout on peut jouer un
peu partout mais là nous on voulait
vraiment un espace
avec 2 avec deux vagues de l'espace un
acte de la place puisque les surfaces
fait 10 mètres de long sur 6 dollars on
attend aussi du public on attendait un
but en fin de journée donc voilà il faut
lui fallait qu'il ya un lieu qui soit en
plus au coeur du quartier c'est
important de le faire à proximité des
habitations donc voilà ça nous semblait
être l'espace que le plus intéressant
pour cette journée très bien et du coup
on a dit rien vous vous êtes le créateur
du tournoi et donc des sites est
fantastique c'est une discipline qui
nous vient du japon pourquoi vous vous
êtes plus lancer là dedans moi je suis
réalisateur je viens de faire un film en
en réalité virtuelle je suis assez
passionné par les nouvelles technologies
et une de mes missions s'est fracturé la
fracture numérique
initialement moi je viens d'un quartier
ici notamment à la verrière je me suis
aperçu que la fracture numérique c'est
un nid de poule qui devient le grand
canyon et du coup on essaie d'avoir un
travail global sur les technologies
d'avenir qui en fait c'est retour vers
le futur maintenant ici à saint quentin
du coup notre objectif c'était de de
faire toucher à ses interactions avec
des hologrammes comprendre que ça existe
qu'on peut avoir du travail qu'on peut
faire des études dans ce sens-là créer
son business et aussi pourquoi pas
devenir un sportif aguerri puisque le
but du tournoi des sites est fantastique
c'est de qualifier la meilleure équipe
pour les championnats de france qui aura
lieu à paris lors de la japan expo on a
et derrière ils peuvent aller aux
championnats d'europe le championnat du
monde je suis sûr qu'on a un vivier
talent ici dans nos quartiers et on a
également un partenaire qui sont les
éditions ki oon qui offre deux supers
lots d d art book
autour du manga autour des des films etc
donc du coup moi en tant qu'artiste
c'est quelque chose qui me passionnait
et
l'intermédiation des différentes
disciplines c'est retour vers le futur
donc on est en plein dedans il ya des
catégories en tout cas pour ce tournoi
donc c'est un peu pour tous les âges à
partir de 7 ans jusqu'aux seniors
finalement c'est accessible à tous on
n'a pas besoin non plus de connaissances
jeu vidéo absolument c'est accessible à
tous et on rend aussi le tournoi
accessible aux personnes à mobilité
réduite ou en fauteuil donc qu'ils ont
une validité du dieu du haut du corps et
on peut jouer à tout âge à son rythme en
fait sans problème de manière mixte donc
c'est hyper accessible et c'est assez
intuitif après pour acquérir un certain
niveau il faut s'entraîner un peu plus
mon programme des robots pour les
affronter et puis progressivement on
arrive à d'autres niveaux donc là on est
dans la première étape où on évangélise
un peu on fait découvrir et en même
temps d'albanese les attentions en
créant réellement un tournoi là on le
fait sur saint quentin en yvelines
demain peut-être dans le nord des
yvelines ont fait dans le 93 et petit à
petit ça permet aussi des rencontres
interquartiers le foot c'est bien mais
là on ramène quelque chose d'autre avec
aussi une pensée culturel et
professionnel justement on parle un peu
des dettes on y reviendra on fera un
rappel des dates est dans un instant
mais pour l'instant je me tourne vers
vous qui êtes série quintavalle est-ce
que vous avez testé vous la discipline
oui bah bien sûr il faut tester avec
deux joueurs fantastiques un nom mais
c'est ouais c'est super c'est ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure ça reste
hyper accessible et c'est la vertu de
cette activité on n'a pas besoin d'être
un super sportif ou d'avoir essayé avant
plutôt sympathique à tester
vous êtes est donc élu en charge des
sports et de la vie associative mais du
coup je voulais vous poser la question
c'est un sport d'un nouveau genre est ce
que d'après vous on pourrait le voir
s'installer durablement dans les
yvelines pourquoi pas après il faut
trouver évidemment des personnes comme
nadir qu'ils puissent vulgariser en tout
cas étant de présenter la ce nouveau
sport
auprès du plus grand nombre et puis
trouver des cadres 6% récup et ça c'est
un peu là c'est un peu la chose
essentielle pour pouvoir monter ce type
d'activité mais en tout cas on est en
train d'engager un très bon partenariat
avec la fiac qui fait un gros boulot il
ya le ados mais ya pas que ça il fait un
travail autour de la réalité augmentée
avec des créations autour de la
sculpture autour de réalisation de films
et donc on souhaite développer à la
verrière toute cette thématique là
autour des nouvelles technologies au
niveau artistique sportif donc voilà on
essaie de mêlée mais tout ça et dieu
sait qu'il ya des talents dans les
quartiers et on a envie de les faire les
faire émerger à travers justement des
années des associations dynamiques tels
que la siac des événements autour de la
réalité augmentée ou qui pourrait
revenir en fait finalement alors cet été
toujours avec nadir on va avoir une
toute une série d'ateliers il y aura du
sport mais aussi de la création de
mangas l'art est augmentée avec de la
sculpture
création de films auraient été virtuel
voilà où on se déplace dans des mondes
imaginaires
le thème pour nous de la fête de la vie
c'est le cirque qui on va développer
tout au long de l'été des activités
autour du cirque aussi donc on va
imaginer des constructions de ce net de
cirque etc les gamins pourront se
balader dans des mondes qu'ils auront
réalisé le faire partager aux autres
donc voilà on s'appuie beaucoup sur sur
nos associations de la ville est là avec
nadir bien content de l'avoir ça ce sera
pour la programmation de la ville n a
dit rubens qu'il ya aussi deux dates on
en parlait tout à l'heure qui sont
prévus dans les dents les ils n'ont
peut-être rappeler ces dates absolument
pour le tournoi des sites est
fantastique quand ado c'est donc
aujourd'hui c'était à la verrière demain
mardi 3 à plaisir ovalie bout à la salle
de la mosaïque mercredi celle en cours à
pierre découverts coubertin jeudi c'est
un mot repas
et vendredi c'est à trappes à l'espace
1901 la maison des associations et la
finale
se rattrape donc l'après midi avec les
meilleures équipes de chaque ville et la
remise des lots donc l'inauguration
était à la verrière la finale se fera à
trappes et on a une journée dans cinq
villes de saint quentin en yvelines
exclusivement pour les habitants de
chacune de ces villes qui se
retrouveront après en finale et on
espère ensuite faire davantage de
tournois et faire découvrir le ados et
cultiver l'esprit des cités fantastiques
sont le tournoi des sites et fantastique
et tout ce qu'on fait à côté qu'on
disait la sculpture le cinéma merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous à tuer de
1 à 10 juin je rappelle à vous êtes le
directeur de l'association pour la
création et à l'innovation artistique et
culturelle et puis merci à vous
également atterri quintavalle d'avoir
été avec nous est elle chargée des
sports et de la vie associative de la
verrière merci à tous les deux
[Musique]
c'est un élan de créativité qui parcourt
cette classe de troisième depuis le mois
de septembre les élèves du collège
saint-augustin de saint-germain-en-laye
option cinéma d'animation planche sur un
court métrage ces derniers sont passés
derrière l'écran le ton d'une année pour
s'initier aux techniques du métier
l'expérimentation du dessin animé donc
la tablette mineuse voilà ça ça a
beaucoup plu je pense aux élèves et puis
ensuite l'expérimentation c'est du
papier découpé donc ça consiste en fait
à fait à dessiner ce qu'on souhaite
désigner et puis à colorer à découper
ensuite à animer en fait au fur et à
mesure chaque jeudi pendant 1h30 29
élèves travaillent sur le projet tous
apportent leur pierre à l'édifice une
aventure collective pour ce film autour
de la végétation et de la civilisation
chacun était chargé de réaliser un
élément pour la vidéo personnages
paysages ou encore des corps moi mon
rôle c'est de faire des arbres parce
qu'on aura un paysage ou faudra faire
les armes de la végétation j'ai découpé
beaucoup de de papier marron pour le
tronc et je le fais ça semblait en
faisant des blocs qui monteront de plus
en plus haut moi je vais dessiner en
manimal donc un sanglier si on va faire
un film dans une forêt donc il y en a
qui doit dessiner des arbres ou les
personnages ou d'autres animaux il y en
a qui ne sont tout simplement les décors
les élèves sont accompagnés dans leur
projet par un intervenant après avoir
découvert les différentes étapes de la
réalisation d'un court métrage
d'animation ils sont initiés à la
technique image par image un dispositif
a été mis en place pour de l'animation
dit stop motion on va installer dès des
appareils photos qui vont permettre de
prendre image par image la décomposition
d'un mouvement là du coup c'est le
papier qui a été utilisée pour pour la
technique du film donc découpé c'est à
dire en fabrique des pantins qui vont
être animés parce qu'ils sont articulés
mais aussi des éléments qui sont de
différentes couleurs de différentes
épaisseurs de papier qui vont évoluer
dans les paysages qui sont pensés
le court métrage sera diffusé sous forme
de projection mapping il sera projeté
sur la façade du collège saint-augustin
lors de la soirée d'inauguration d'un
nouveau bâtiment le 24 mai prochain
[Musique]
en sport énorme joie dé versailles et ce
samedi sur la pelouse de saint malo
après plusieurs mois en tête du
championnat de nationale 2 le fc
versailles 78 validé sa montée à
l'échelon supérieur
après sa victoire en terre bretonne sur
le score de 2 à 1
dans le même temps chartres seule équipe
qui pouvait encore monter elle s'est
inclinée face à caen cette montée en 3e
division espéré en début de saison est
une première historique pour le club
pour valider définitivement le titre de
champion de nationale 2 les versaillais
devront prendre le meilleur sur
plabennec et le samedi 14 mai à domicile
dans leur stade mont boron l'occasion de
marquer encore plus c'est l'histoire de
ce club né d'une fusion en 1989
[Musique]